Metrosexuals; youthful men who spare no expense in the cultivation of their outward appearance...
...are continuing to increase...
...and the metrosexual revolution...
...has meant that there is no longer a stigma attached...
...to men wanting healthy skin and a fair complexion.
The typical metrosexual is a young man with money to spend,...
...living in or near a metropolis; because that's where all the best shops,...
...clubs, gyms and hairdressers are.
He might be officially gay, straight or bisexual,...
...but this is utterly immaterial because he has clearly fallen in love with himself.
62 percent of men between 19 and 50...
...are estimated to have used "cosmeceuticals" or massage packs.
Nowadays, large Korean cosmetic companies...
...may generate more than 10% of their income from men...
...and that number looks ready to explode upwards.
Another reason for the flowering of metrosexuals...
...is related to the rising divorce rate of nearly 50 percent...
...coupled with the rise in the number of single moms.
As a result, many young males come to take on their mother's spending habits.
In addition, income throughout Asia is rising...
...and has contributed to the number of men who view spending as entertainment.
And becoming beautiful doesn't come cheap.
How much do metrosexuals spend?
In Bangkok, metrosexual men spent 6.4 million won to 8.9 million won...
...which is three to four times more than their more down-to-earth brothers.